for john gray it'll be start number five
in five appearances two wins and a loss
2.42 the earned run average john coming
off a very good outing against the
astros on tuesday six and two thirds
innings allowing a run on three hits
with four walks and six strikeouts
overall this year 22-2 22 and a third
innings 14 hits 11 walks 21 strikeouts
six earned runs allowed and only one
home run served up the pitch swaying and
a miss got him with the slider john
starts the afternoon off with the
strikeout big night rhys hoskins last
night two homer game pitch breaking ball
strike three call
hoskins down on strikes back to back
punch outs for john gray two outs here's
bryce harper price is one for eight in
this series 3-1 pitch to harper and a
high fly ball to right center field
going back is dazza it is
long gone
a solo home run for bryce harper
and the phillies jump out to a
one-nothing lead here in the first
inning another excellent at-bat by bryce
harper right here he lays off that one
high fastball does not chase it gray
tries to come back to him with a
backdoor slider and it stays out over
the plate and he stays right on it ball
spinning in the middle of the plate and
bryce does not miss it takes a nice
short swing with it and his two-strike
approach has just been outstanding this
year chase anderson 0-2 with the 4-1-5
era 13-inch pitch 10 hits teams only
hitting 204 but the damage has been
like it is in his career the home run
ball and he's got three already
in the small
sample size this year uh he needs to
have some finish on his curveball
consistently last time out it was it was
better use it a little bit more
effectively against the giants
and obviously if he's going to miss make
sure it's off the plate the ball's in
two strikes
shot the other way gloved by bowm
and he gets it across the time one out
here's the three two swinging a miss he
got him looked like a change up that
time and hamson going down and going
after it i love the pitch choice because
previous pitch
was a change of and it was virtually the
same spot trevor story will see if he
can do what bryce harper did out of the
three hole for the phillies philadelphia
leading in here one nothing
and a change up all four he draws a walk
with two outs here in the bottom of the
first
there goes story here's the pitch swung
on and hammered to deep center field
moniak going back to the track he's got
room he makes the catch
a couple of feet from that 415 marker in
dead center field
mickey money echo for three in the
series
zodiac lines it toward left field
that'll be in for base hit
may todd will hold up at second two on
two outs really nice job of hitting
right there moniak staying on all of his
base hits and most of his bases have
been the other way so gray lets the
seven and eight hole hitters reach but
can get out of trouble if he can get his
counterpart anderson one two to anderson
swag and a miss he got him with the
slider strikeout number three for john
gray one nothing philly's middle of two
dom nunia is over five in the series
and the line drive basically to right
field grown heading to third he's being
waved home the throw by bryce harper is
in time he got his hand what a throw by
harp jt again went out and got it and
then went after crone and never let him
get to the plate the bryce harper show
going on right now it's not a bad thing
no and i think it's probably going to
happen again here comes harper who
homered his first time up
and he guffs one deep to right center
field wow forget about that one it goes
right down the stairwell
that was smoked and it had some distance
on it it's two-nothing phillies
that may be one of the furthest home
runs i've ever seen hit there and
there's been a a lot of them 468-footer
sweet one to sit and watch fastball down
out over the plate and that ball was
absolutely crushed it's velasquez in
case uh they didn't realize wanted a
single home run so everybody knew it so
anderson in a spot here in the fourth
with the phillies up two to nothing
dazza at the plate mcmahon at second and
crone at first
this ball driven to center it'll get at
least one home tracked down out there by
moniak and uh krone's gonna tag go from
second to third mcmahon crosses home
plate with the rocky's first run two to
one phillies gray was at the plate with
a couple of men on in the second and he
struck out the 1-2 lined up the middle
base hit john gray
coming on in is cj crone rbi single for
the rockies pitcher and it's a 2-2 ball
game
john
a career batting average below 100
that's just his 11th run batted in in
205
at bats but on a day in which the
rockies have not always cashed in
opportunities and orimel tapia now will
try and put the rockies in the lead
pull to right base hit
nunez will score going first to third is
gray now moving up is tapia
rockies lead at three to two he'll come
on to get trevor story ninth man to bat
in the inning three runs in gray at
third tapia at second and hamson over at
first see what he can do with the 2-2
pitch it's on the way and it's hit high
and deep and gone
over and out of here to left field
grand slam trevor story rocky seven
phillies two he
got it all they wanted something to
cheer about they got
something to cheer about susie hits his
slider he knows it immediately he looks
over to the dugout he's yelling at his
boys
let's go i love it lead off single by
fuentes
and this is line to left and it gets
past
mccutchen he's going to go all the way
to the wall fuentes will score easily
heading to third is nunez he'll get a
stop sign there
8-2 colorado phillies have to bring the
infield in down 8-2 tapia
howard with the one two and it's bounced
to
hoskins who has to back up to field it
he'll get it to first for the out but
dom nunez scores a productive out by
rymel he knocks in his second run of the
afternoon which decrone is pretty well
hit the left center field how about
another long ball
yes sir
touch him all time for cj
chrome
his third home run
a pair of rbis and the rockies lead it
12-2 one and two
jordan sheffield one pitch away from
leading the handshake line
he's got him
ball game over the rockies win this
afternoon 12-2
[Applause]